[Music]
hello everyone
in the previous lecture we were
discussing
about the volume polynomial solution
forms
to the by harmonic equation and at the
end we were
discussing about uh generating solutions
of practical interest
in some real problems so what i meant to
say
was that uh
suppose so so when we were talking about
the second degree
terms we were only considering uh in the
previous lecture only considering these
kinds of second degree terms and we saw
that
quite well these
did produce some kinds of non-zero
stresses and was
uh it was fairly interesting but what i
meant was
suppose we had some combinations of
loads which would
uh which would not be individually
satisfied
by only this cubic terms but or by only
this second degree terms what then would
we possibly combine them
okay so that is the question so it turns
out
that there is indeed such a principle
which we can follow so this is the
principle of superposition which very
much holds true here
okay so the principle of superposition
so suppose for our biharmonic
equation therefore phi equal to 0
we find one solution which is
let's say given by phi 1
and suppose we have another solution
which is phi 2.
now let's say phi 1 is of some second
degree
and let's say as a specific example phi
2
this is of third degree what the
principle of superposition tells us
is that because our biharmonic equation
is a linear equation okay so please do
not confuse yourself
with the degree and the order of this by
harmonic equation
it is true very much that the order okay
the order of the derivatives present in
this bi-harmonic equation
are fourth fourth order but
the individual terms are very much
linear we do not have any nonlinear
terms
in this by harmonic equation okay
because
of this linear nature of this governing
differential equation the by harmonic
equation
it is very much possible to construct
solutions
because okay so
given a a new uh practical situation
it is very much possible to combine
one solution with another solution to
produce
a new solution okay and probably this
solution is what is going to satisfy
the physical uh requirements of
the currents of a of a particular
problem
okay so this is very much important this
only works
okay it only works
because
of the linear nature
of the bi-harmonic equation
and we will actually see examples of
this kind of superposition going on
when you actually solve the problems
so here we should be actually writing
because of the linear
because of the linear nature of the
bioharmonic equation
okay let us be absolutely clear about
this
let me go back to the previous page so
you note here
that this is a fourth ordered derivative
this also is a fourth order derivative
of course mixed in nature
and this is a fourth order derivative
but none of these terms
are non-linear in nature so for example
uh for example if i just
use the rough column here
you see this term
is linear okay it's fourth order but
it's linear
this term
again it's fourth order mixed
derivatives but it is linear however
suppose we have a term like this del
square
pi del x square times
del square phi del y square then it
becomes non-linear
okay then it is non-linear
uh it will it will also be non-linear if
suppose
if we have a term like phi
multiplied with del square phi del x
square we don't
have these kinds of things but i'm just
saying okay uh
from in from from general knowledge of
of differential equations
that this is also going to be non-linear
okay or suppose you have del phi del x
times del phi del x that also will
contribute to the non-linearity
okay we don't have those kinds of
inconvenient terms
everything is very much nice and linear
and that is why it is possible
to superpose solutions like this and
this is an extremely extremely
uh powerful uh
powerful principle of when we actually
solve problems okay it will help us to
solve
many many problems of practical interest
by superposing
posing some of the elementary solutions
that we know from very simple
situations okay next another
very important practical consideration
is uh is the saint finance principle
so for that let me go to the next page
many of you have already come across
this principle
okay so the main finance principle
very very important
and for that let me take a concrete
example
so suppose we have this kind of a
situation as we have already found out
when we took the second degree terms
okay let me just go back to that page
when we're considering the second degree
terms
so we had this thing okay now as a very
simple special case
you forget or you consider that we don't
have this
a 1 1 term so let's set a 1 1 equal to 0
a 2
to 0 equal to 0 and let only the a 0 2
be non-zero okay so what we what we are
doing is
we are saying that i let it be just a 0
to y square
so as a result what this is going to
give us
is sigma xx is equal to
twice a 0 2 that's it a constant
sigma yy equal to 0 and sigma
xy is also going to be equal to 0.
so what is this solving so uh
so it sounds a little bit weird to ask
like this that we are finding a solution
and then we are looking at
uh at the the physical problem which
which it might solve but that's
that's the way to think about uh about
things
when you're uh approaching problems
using the a distress function so first
you find the solution
and then you try to look for appropriate
problems uh
which it is solving okay so you
understand that
the sigma x is a constant basically
means that you have a situation like
this
so this is your uniform loading
okay so perhaps if a02 is
is positive then what we have depicted
through this kind of tensile nature of
the loading that's perfectly fine
however uh suppose instead of this
suppose instead of this we have a more
more realistic scenario which we come
across
often in our undergraduate studies
where you have this kind of a
rectangular domain maybe a beam or
something
and where the loading is not actually
applied in such uniform nature or by
in such a uniform manner rather it is
given like this
okay this is very very common we have
you have drawn this diagram innumerable
times
in your undergraduate days okay so this
is a
like a pure tension case uh depicted by
this kind of
point loading okay what then is it
perhaps possible
to say that the that the solution to
this problem
also is given by this so your immediate
answer should be no
okay so this problem and this problem
are not exactly the same thing
there is very much a difference between
a uniform loading and this kind of point
loading
right now the good thing
here is that according to the saint
finance principle so what he
what he said was that yes this is very
much true that
uh these stresses that are generated in
this case and the stresses which are
generated in this case they're going to
be different
fine but actually the difference is only
going to show up
only near the very very near to the
point of loading so if you
if you actually zoom into this zone if
you zoom into this zone
then you will find that certainly the
stresses which are here which are
actually
mathematically uniform and here not
uniform
okay there it's going to be very high
stress in this very low stress here very
low stress here
but suppose suppose and this is what
saint vinod's principle
okay the hurt and blood of the infinite
principle is
that if you stay away from these ends
okay if you stay away from these ends
okay if you just stay away from the ends
then for all intents and purposes the
the the stress field which you will
find for this kind of a problem and this
kind of a problem
is the same is the same as long as
the loading here and the loading here
they are statically equivalent
okay so what i mean to say is suppose it
so happens that
this is some kind of a sigma xx value
and this is some tension t if it happens
that t is equal to sigma xx
ea over this entire area
okay over this entire area if this kind
of thing is
true and of course this is eccentric
loading so that you do not
uh do not end up with any any bending
moments here
okay you do not have any bending moments
here uh nor should you have any bending
moments here
so only then you can say that this case
is statically equivalent to this case
okay so
what we are saying basically is that for
statically equivalent loadings
the stress field is going to be the same
as long as we stay away from the ends
so i have written this in a in a very
utilitarian fashion
what i mean from from the ends is what i
implicitly mean from the ends
here is that uh you you stay away from
those ends or from those zones
where the load is being actually applied
okay as long as you stay away from those
zones
you'll be safe okay so for example if
you take a cut section here suppose
okay suppose here then you're good
okay the stress field that you are going
to have here suppose you take a cut
section
here and you take a cut section here
they're going to be for all intents and
purposes
the same thing okay that's all there is
to it so that's the same evidence
principle
now it may seem like okay this is what
was the big deal about it
but you will see that many of the
solutions that we generate
from our considerations of the area
stress function and our notion or our
and our ideas about the polynomial uh
solution forms
they will be uh they will be of this
nature
okay which are uh which are not
uh which are not so commonly uh
like practically done practically done
is this kind of a thing
okay uh so in order to go from
a practically applied load nature to
this kind of the load nature
which you actually require for your uh
for your airy stress function approach
uh there the missing link is this saint
finance principle
i hope i have been able to make myself
clear so with these considerations
uh especially about the principle of
superposition which also seems quite
straightforward to understand but again
very important and again the saint
as principle which is again at least in
a handwriting
fashion is quite intuitive to understand
uh
so based on these things uh and some
clever applications of
the of various combinations of this of
the the stress functions
uh we can go on to solve some problems
all right so with this i will
end this part of the lecture thank you
very much